-Have you guys ever noticed
when you start typing
something on Google,
it automatically tries to
complete the search for you?
Yeah, it autofills
what you're looking for.
But sometimes their suggestions
are a little off, I think.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time for Google Autofails.
Here we go.
-♪ Google Autofails ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
[ Applause ]
-Look at what I typed in today.
Today I typed in,
"How do we come together
as human beings to prevent..."
And these three things
popped up.
"...global warming."
"...the next pandemic."
..."Golden bachelor in Paradise"
No, no one wants that.
I don't want to see that.
[ Applause ]
Here's another one I typed in.
I typed in "Is Taylor Swift
the reason why..."
And it said,
"...Travis Kelce
is selling more jerseys?"
"..movie theaters
are making more money?"
"...Michaels has been out of
beads for the last six months?"
I go, that's
that's probably why,
but that's not
what I was typing.
[ Applause ]
After that I typed in,
"I've never seen a bigger,
more chaotic mess than..."
It said, "...The House
of Representatives."
"...the airport
The day before Thanksgiving."
...the milk table at Starbucks."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Disaster.
Next up, I typed in,
"How to hide from..."
and it auto-filled,
"...ghosts."
"..goblins."
"...guys with acoustic guitars."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Hey there Delilah ♪
♪ There is something ♪
♪ I will tell you ♪
-After that, I typed in,
"How many different people..."
and it said,
"...are in the US?"
"...are in the world?"
"...will star as Elvis
in a major motion picture?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Elvis ]
Well, you ain't seen this side
of the story yet, man.
[ Laughter ]
You ain't seen this side
of me yet, man.
-Come on. Hiyah!
-[ Normal voice ]
Next up, I typed in,
"Why does Travis Kelce's
brother, Jason..."
and it said,
"...wear number 62?"
"...play for Philadelphia?"
"...look like a baby
with a beard?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wee!
-You are so cute!
-Here's another one,
I typed in,
"Best ways to pretend..."
It said,
"...to be sick."
"...to be smart."
"...to care about
your co-worker's
Fantasy football team."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you traded him.
-[ Laughs ] Wow.
-You traded him?
Oh, my God, that's terrible.
And you traded him?
You did it.
-Ah!
Oh, I can't believe it.
-Wow.
-And he didn't --
He wouldn't trade you back?
-Oh, man.
-Wow.
And he didn't play.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, wow.
-He got injured in the game?
-He, in the game?
-Oh, man!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I got to go back to the --
my files.
-Wait.
[ Laughs]
What files do
you have to get to?
-Yeah, just a bunch of files.
-Wait, you're telling me
he's not playing?
He's sick this week?
Wow, man.
That's terrible.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, I typed in,
"Tips to fall asleep..."
and it said,
"...fast."
"...early."
"...while still scrolling TikTok
until 4:00 a.m."
Stick around, everybody.
When we come back,
we're doing something
fun and scary with
Cameron Diaz.